a beginning is the time for taking the
most delicate care that the balances are
correct this every sister of the bin
each ezarik knows to begin your study of
the life of MU Adeeb then take care that
you first place him in his time born in
the 57th year of the padishah Emperor
Shaddam the forth and take the most
special care that you locate mu Adeeb in
his place the planet Arrakis do not be
deceived by the fact that he was born on
Caledon and lived his first 15 years
there Arrakis the planet known as doom
is forever his place
[Music]
10,000 years before the start of doom
mankind led a crusade violently
expunging all thinking machines from the
Imperium it was called the but Larian
jihad and its chief commandment still
remains within their OC Bible thou shalt
not make a machine in the likeness of a
human mind the target of the jihad was a
machine attitude as much as the machines
Leto said humans had set those machines
up to usurp our sense of beauty our
necessary self 'dom out of which we make
living judgments naturally the machines
were destroyed the punishment they're
after for owning or developing
artificial intelligence was immediate
death the fall of thinking machines
would mean that humankind would have to
depend on itself for all its computing
needs and this is where Mentats come
into play Mentats are the human
computers of the Imperium their mental
abilities are ultimately honed to the
point where they have become superior to
even the ancient thinking machines most
of the Great Houses employ a mint at 4
they possess exceptional cognitive
abilities of memory and perception that
are the foundations for supper logical
hypothesizing also meant at abilities
can be greatly increased by the taking
of Sappho juice the substance extracted
from the roots found on the planet Equis
but the consumption of this chemical
leads to addiction the min tak were not
the only replacement for thinking
machines that developed during the
turmoil following the but Larian jihad
the Bene Gesserit sisterhood also came
to prominence during this time as well
as the spacing guild whose prescient
powers granted by the spice melange
makes safe and instantaneous space
travel throughout the universe possible
the galactic feudal empire which would
arise after the butler in jihad would
last for many thousands of years until
the rise of the god emperor at the start
of Doon the human race has scattered
throughout the galaxy and populated many
planets each ruled by aristocratic
houses who each owe their loyalty to the
imperial house Kirino Emperor Shaddam
Kirino the fourth now since the imperial
throne in this time the lancer ad was
the group that represented all the Great
Houses throughout the galaxy within the
Lancer ad the High Council ruled and was
overseen by the Emperor at the start of
doom the emperor has grown to fear House
Atreides the Duke Leto Atreides had
become more and more popular within the
land surrett and it was said that the
talent of Latos own fighting force was
beginning to rival the Emperor's own
dreaded imperial sardick our soldiers
the Emperor Shaddam Kirino the fourth
decided that he must do away with House
Atreides the feud between the Atreides
and the harkonnens had been going on for
centuries the emperor would use this to
his advantage the planet Arrakis was
currently lorded over by the genius and
despicable Baron Vladimir her Conan with
the help of the Baron the Emperor
created a plan designed to trap and
eliminate House Atreides the thief 'dom
the desert planet Arrakis the source of
the spice melange had been given over to
the Duke Leto Atreides but the gift was
poisoned and House Atreides expected as
much the Duke Leto Atreides lived the
majority of his life on the paradise
world of Caledon in the 20 years prior
to the start of doom
he had ruled over the planet with his
concubine the bene Jesuit Lady Jessica
by his side Jessica was the result of
the bene Jesuit breeding program The
Sisterhood had intended to breed her
with the Duke Leto and produce a
daughter who could then breed with a har
Conan's son this union
they believed would produce their quiz
at satiric the lady Jessica was provided
with the most advanced been a Jesuit
training available and carried the fate
of the sisterhood within her genes but
she betrayed them her love for Leto
eventually grew so strong that Jessica
disobeyed her orders to have only
daughters and produced a son their first
child Paul Atreides in doing this
Jessica not only disobeyed direct orders
from the sisterhood she betrayed a
general understanding held within the
sisterhood the bene Jesuit are beyond
love love had nothing to do with it
Reverend mothers did not act from such
mundane motives love clouded reason it
diverted the sisters from their duties
love could be tolerated only where it
caused no immediate and obvious
disruptions or where it served the
larger purposes of the Bene Gesserit
otherwise it was to be avoided always
though it remained an object of
disquieting watchfulness a life without
love can be devoted more intensely to
the sisterhood love damnable love
weakening love love leads to misery the
sisterhood had planned to brief
Jessica's daughter with a her Conan's
son uniting the two houses and producing
their long-awaited quiz etc
but now they would have to adapt their
plans the son Paul was raised on Caledon
and trained in the bene Jesuit way when
the sisterhood realized - what Jessica
had done they were furious but the many
Jesuit adapt and the boy was either the
quizlets had Iraq or he was not
accompanying House Atreides to Arrakis
were several servants and teachers
notably Duncan Idaho swords Master
gurney Halleck war master who fear
Howard mint at and master of Assassins
and Willington nuit soup doctor the soup
inter-school is devoted to finding cures
for the many ailments that afflict
mankind in the Dune universe they are
widely considered to be superior to all
other medical groups doctor Willington
Mui graduated from the souq School in
ten thousand one twelve AG through
imperial conditioning the school renders
its students incapable of inflicting
harm
once on Arrakis House Atreides takes up
residence at the home previously
occupied by house Harkonnen it is full
of traps and although mentat do fear
Howard locates and disarms most of them
a hunter seeker attacks all in his room
and nearly kills him Paul slipped out of
been headed for the bookcase door that
opened into the closet he stopped at the
sound behind him turned the carved
headboard of the bed was folding down
onto the spot where he had been sleeping
Paul froze and immobility saved his life
from behind the headboard slipped a tiny
hunter seeker no more than five
centimetres long
Paul recognized it at once a common
assassination weapon that every child of
royal blood learned about at an early
age
it was a ravening sliver of meadow
guided by some nearby hand and eye it
could burrow into moving flesh and shew
its way up nerve channels to the nearest
vital organ Paul knows that if he calls
for help the device will kill whoever
opens the door he manages to survive the
situation by utilizing his unique
skillset and ultimately destroying the
device in doing so Paul also saves a
life a Freeman housekeeper the shout-out
Mapes as thanks she gives Paul a
valuable piece of information there is a
traitor in their midst though she could
not say who do Plato is furious over the
attempt on his 15 year old son's life
Paul tells his father of the traitor in
their midst and Leto admits to
discussing the possibility several times
before with Atreides mint at the fair
Howerton when speaking with do fear
later later receives another piece of
information a scrap of a letter burying
the barren her Conan's own seal has been
discovered and it seems to identify the
traitor
it says H o will never suspect and when
the blow falls on him from a beloved end
its source alone should be enough to
destroy him the note was under the
Barons own seal and I have authenticated
the seal your suspicion is obvious the
Duke said and his voice was suddenly
cold I sooner cut off my arms than hurt
you
Howard said my lord what if the lady
Jessica Leto said and he felt the anger
consuming him couldn't you ring the
facts out of this Pardee unfortunately
Hardy was no longer among the living
when we intercepted the courier the
courrier uncertain did not know what he
carried
I see Leto shook his head thinking what
a slimy piece of business there can't be
anything in it I know my woman my lord
if know the Duke Bart there is a mistake
here that we cannot ignore to my lord
she's been with me for 16 years there
have been countless opportunities for
you yourself investigated the school and
the woman howard spoke bitterly things
have been known to escape me it's
impossible I tell you the harkonnens
want to destroy the Atreides line
meaning Paul - they've already tried
once could a woman conspire against her
own son in the days before House
Atreides left the planet Caledon for
doom the Bene Jesuit Reverend Mother
Gaius Helen mohim came to visit the lady
Jessica Jessica had betrayed the
sisterhood used her bene Jesuit skills
to bear a son against their orders and
trained him in the Bene jesuit way the
sisterhood is furious with Jessica for
her transgression but the boy Paul must
be tested with the gum Jabar nonetheless
the gham jabbar which is also known as
the high-handed enemy is a meta cyanide
poison needle that sits upon a thimble
which is attached to a person's
fingertip the many Jesuit make use of
the gum Jabar when they test the
humanity of certain people the device
would be held against the person's neck
and used as a deterrent for the person
backing out of the test the test would
determine whether an individual's
awareness was stronger than their
instincts if their awareness of the gum
Jabbar's presence was strong enough it
would override their instincts to
withdraw from the test which involved
great physical pain one does not obtain
food safety freedom by instinct alone
animal consciousness does not extend
beyond the given moment nor into the
idea
that its victims may become extinct an
animal destroys and does not produce
animal pleasures remain close to
sensation levels and avoid the
perceptual the human requires a
background grid through which to see his
universe focused consciousness by choice
this forms your grid bodily integrity
follows nerve blood flow according to
the deepest awareness of cell needs all
things cells beings are impermanent
strive for flow permanence within the
test of the gum Jabbar was to determine
pols potential and also to a certain
extent determine how much of a danger he
might be if he was weak or undisciplined
he could potentially become a danger to
the Bene Jesuit breeding plan and would
thereafter need to be dealt with
perhaps killed or subjected to
additional training that likely would
have resulted in him being taken from
Lady Jessica and given into the care of
another Binnie jesuit sister if he
however proved strong enough he would be
deemed useful to the breeding plan and
allowed to remain under the care of lady
Jessica while they calculated the best
potential use for him the Reverend
Mother telling Paul that the test would
determine whether or not he was human is
in reality an oversimplification of the
truth used to justify her actions while
also allowing her to maintain been in
Jesuit secrets the test may on some
level test humanity but the actions of a
bene Jesuit are often layered and
possess many implications Paul in fact
ends up withstanding more pain than any
female child before had withstood
Paul passes the test he is human the
Reverend Mother then tells Paul of the
quiz ATS hadurok and of his foretold
power and also of the fact that any man
before who has been tested for being the
quiz at cedrac had died
the Reverend Mother then reveals to Paul
and Jessica a terrible prophecy when you
live upon Arrakis
she said Carla the land is empty the
moons will be your friends the Sun your
enemy Paul since his mother come up
beside him away from her post guarding
the door she had looked at the Reverend
Mother and asked do you see no hope your
reverence not for the father
Helen mo Humes words seemed to suggest
that something terrible will befall
House Atreides after its arrival on
Arrakis and the Duke will not survive
Leto did not truly believe that Jessica
was the traitor he knew that the letter
was merely a ploy by the Baron Harkonnen
to wound and confuse House Atreides
through fear Howard however does not
trust Jessica Jessica discovers how its
mistrust of her when a drunken Duncan
Idaho stumbles into the Atreides castle
and reveals that he too suspects Jessica
the lady Jessica is shocked and confused
by this revelation and attempts to
convince Howard that his beliefs are
illogical Jessica tries to explain that
it is more logical to believe that it is
the harkonnens that are making him
suspicious of her but how it will not
listen Jessica decides that the only way
to convince Howard that she is innocent
is to prove that if she wanted Leto dead
she could have done so long ago I don't
trust your many Jesuit motives he said
you may think you can look through a man
you may think you can make a man do
exactly what you you poor fool through
fear she raged
he's scowled pushing himself back in the
chair whatever rumors you've heard about
our schools she said the truth is far
greater
if I wish to destroy the Duke or you or
any other person within my reach
you could not stump me and she thought
why do I let pride drive such words out
of me this is not the way I was trained
this is not how I must shocked him
Howard slipped a hand beneath his tunic
where he kept a tiny projector of poison
darts
she wears no shield he thought is this a
brag she makes I could slay her now but
ah the consequences if I am wrong
Jessica saw the gesture towards his
pocket and said let us pray violence
shall never be necessary between us
a worthy prayer he agreed meanwhile the
sickness spreads among us she said I
must ask you again isn't it more
reasonable to suppose that the
harkonnens that planted this suspicion
to pit the two of us against each other
we appeared to return to stalemate he
said she sighed thinking he's almost
ready for it the Duke and I are father
and mother surrogates to our people
she said the position he hasn't married
you Howard said she forced herself to
calmness thinking a good repost that but
he'll not marry anyone else she said not
as long as I live and we are surrogates
as I've said to break up this natural
order in our affairs to disturb disrupt
and confuse us which target offers
itself most enticing ly to the
harkonnens
he sense the direction she was taking
and his brows drew down in a lowering
scowl the Duke
she asked attractive target yes but no
one with the possible exception of Paul
is better guarded me I tipped them
surely but they must know the many
Jesuit make difficult targets and there
is a better target one whose duties
create necessarily a monstrous blind
spot one to whom suspicion is as natural
as breathing one who builds his entire
life on innuendo and mystery she darted
her right hand toward him you how it
started to leap from his chair
I have not dismissed you through fear
she flared the old mint at almost fell
back into the chair so quickly did his
muscles betray him she smiled without
mirth now you know something of the real
training they give us she said how it
tried to swallow in a dry throat her
command had been regal preemptory
uttered in a tone and manner that he
found completely irresistible his body
had obeyed her before he could think
about it nothing could have prevented
his response not logic not passion and
anger nothing to do what she had done
spoke of a sensitive intimate knowledge
of the person thus commanded a depth
control he had not dreamed possible she
had used the many Jesuit power of voice
on him forcing him to obey her words
this however does not go as planned
instead of do fear being more confident
in the fact that lady Jessica is not
interested in hurting Leto who fear is
even more disturbed and considers
Jessica even more dangerous than he had
before but Jessica was not the traitor
there is a traitor among slim but
someone that could have never been
suspected all the while House Atreides
had been on Arrakis the Baron Vladimir
Harkonnen had been plotting their
destruction he indeed planted the letter
to frame Jessica and the move suspicion
even further away from the true traitor
the Baron Harkonnen is a monstrosity of
a man a sadistic pedophile and rapist he
is grossly fat and must be held up by
suspense errs despite of all this the
Baron is also a genius and is recognized
for his remarkable insight in knowing
people this is demonstrated in the way
he has developed the roles of his
nephews the brutish class soon Robin and
the Barons favored fade ratha and also
demonstrated in the maintenance of the
Barons own mint at the twisted peiter
DeVries the Baron has proven throughout
his time as the leader of a major house
to be incredibly cruel and has earned
house Harkonnen
its reputation slavery murder and
torture on a wide scale find no fault in
the Barons mind the harkonnens and the
Atreides have been feuding for
generations the Baron now had the chance
to destroy the house once and for all
and with the Emperor backing him he did
not know how he could fail and he knew
that the traitor amongst the Atreides
would not be detected because he had
recruited the help of a man conditioned
against doing harm to eliminate House
Atreides Vladimir Harkonnen had taken
the soup dr. yu his wife Juan a prisoner
threatening her with torture and even
death unless you we complied with his
demands
dr. ue would go down as the first
instance ever of Imperial conditioning
being broken youi could avoid detection
from Jessica's troops sensing abilities
due to the skills he had learned from
his wife Juana who was trained by the
Beni jezzer at school as well under the
cover of night house Harkonnen launches
a devastating attack on House Atreides
ue disables the protective shields
around the Atreides palace and House
Atreides soon falls to the Emperor's old
sardick our soldiers disguised as her
Conan's
the Emperor does not wish his hand and
this to be known
Leto and Jessica and Paul are sedated
with drugs
NUI also replaces one of the Dukes teeth
with a false one that could emit a
poison gas new he encourages the Duke to
kill the Baron with the poison gas when
he is close enough to him the Duke
himself would die as well but the Baron
would be no more Leto is taken prisoner
by the Baron and Jessica and Paul are
taken to the deep desert to die in the
Sun without still suits or be consumed
by the sandworms survival on Arrakis is
brutal water is the most precious thing
on the planet
rather than spikes Frank Herbert has
stated that the scarcity of water on
Arrakis is meant to be an analogue for
the scarcity of oil on earth the surface
of the planet is almost entirely dry
doomed deserts
hence the planets less formal named dune
the heat in the desert is sweltering and
miserable without a still suit to
recycle the body's water one will be
dead within hours during the daytime the
Fremen inhabitants of the desert even
with still suits only travel at night
while in the owner Thopter a flying
vehicle driven by her conan henchman
Paul and Jessica used their Benny Jesuit
skills to get free of their bondage
understanding some of the strange powers
possessed by students of the sisterhood
the Baron insisted that the lady Jessica
be gagged the entire time he also
insisted that one of the three captors
be death and therefore immune to
Jessica's ability of voice but the fools
did not listen to the Barons words the
deaf man known as Scarface was left
behind Paul for the first time manages
to use the Benny desert power of voice
convincing the men to remove Jessica's
gag and when it is done the highly
skilled Jessica manipulates one man to
kill the other and remove Paul's bonds
as well Paul then skillfully crushes the
man's heart killing him instantly
this is the first man Paul has ever
killed hidden within the ornithopter all
and Jessica discover a bundle containing
Latos ducal ring still suits food and
other provisions clearly this bundle was
left by the dr. Yui he is the only one
that would have had access to the doctor
and Leto serene Yui does this out of
some sense of guilt and responsibility
for his betrayal of House Atreides after
the assault on House Atreides Yui
finally confronts the Baron demanding to
know what has become of his wife and as
you he has already suspected the Baron
had killed her but no matter to him he
had already set a deadly trap for the
Baron dr. Yui was killed then by the
Barons twisted mentat Piter and would
forever go down in history as a traitor
the Baron then has Duke Leto brought to
him he demands to know where Jessica and
Paul have fled but the Duke truly does
not know and would never tell the
despicable Baron even if he did the
Baron threatens to torture the dupe but
Leto remembers the secret weapon that
dr. Yui had planted on him
Leto stared across the table wondering
why he waited the tooth would end it all
quickly still it had been good much of
his life he found himself remembering an
antenna kite up dangling in the show
blue sky of Caledon and Paul laughing
with joy at the sight of it and he
remembered the sunrise here on Arrakis
ha strata of the shield-wall mellowed by
dust haze too bad
the baron muttered he pushed himself
back from the table stood up likely in
his suspense errs and hesitated seeing a
change come over the Duke he saw the man
draw a deep breath jawline stiffen the
ripple of muscle there as the duke
clamped his mouth shut how he fears me
the Baron thought shocked by the fear
that the Baron might escape him
Leto bid sharply on the capsule tooth
felt it break opened his mouth and
expelled the biting vapor he could taste
it as it formed on his tongue the Baron
grew smaller a figure seen in a
tightening tunnel Leto heard a gasp
beside his ear
the silky voiced one peiter I got him to
my turn
what's wrong the rumbling voice was far
away Leto sensed memories rolling in his
mind the old toothless mutterings of
hags the room the table the Baron the
pair of terrified eyes blue within blue
the eyes all compressed around him in
ruined symmetry there was a man with a
boot toe chin a toy man falling the toy
man had a broken nose slanted to the
left and offbeat metronome caught
forever at the start of an upward stroke
Leto heard the crash of crockery so
distant a roaring in his ears his mind
was a bin without end catching
everything everything that had ever been
ever shout every whisper every silence
one thought remained to him Leto saw in
formless light rays of black
the day the flesh shapes and the flushed
the day shapes the thought struck him
with a sense of fullness he knew he
could never explain silence the twisted
mentat Piter is killed instantly
and the rest of the men in the room die
as well including the noble Duke Leto
but the baron manages to escape in the
nick of time and preserves his own life
now lost in the desert all and Jessica
must find a way to survive it is during
this time however that Paul's powers
truly begin to awaken Paul since the
hyper alertness of his mind greeting her
reactions computing on minutiae you see
it now
he said satellites watched the terrain
below there are things in the deep
desert that will not bear frequent
inspection you're suggesting that the
guild itself controls this planet
she was so slow no he said the Freeman
they are paying the guild for privacy
paying in a coin that is freely
available to anyone with desert power
spice this is more than a second
approximation answer this is the
straight line computation depend on it
Paul Jessica said you're not a mint at
yet you can't know for sure hell I'll
never be a mint act he said I am
something else a freak Paul how can you
say such leave me alone as Paul's
abilities heighten more and more becomes
clear to him for one the freeman hold
much more power than initially believed
the Freeman people who exist in greater
numbers than anyone had ever expected
are the secret power on Arrakis
they are overlooked by most members of
the Imperium and are considered to be
primitive savages Frank Herbert based
several parts of their society and
culture off of real-life Arabic
traditions
the Fremen had come to the planet
Arrakis thousands of years ago
over the centuries that they have been
on doomed only the fittest have survived
their culture has adapted a way of life
to survive and even thrive in the harsh
conditions of the planet the Freeman are
also known to be amazing fighters
Freeman's society is organized into
communities of people called C etches
leading each CH is an e on the Arabic
word meaning deputy or representative of
authority who ascends to leadership upon
defeating his predecessor in combat
proving himself to be the strongest
member of the tribe
a notable characteristic of the freeman
is their blue in blue eyes the result of
spiced addiction the spice is everywhere
on Arrakis all Freeman developed blue in
blue eyes well before they reach
adulthood now in the desert plains of
Arrakis exposed to more spice than ever
before Paul's awareness expands
dramatically his vision is clearer than
anyone before him
if you are not the quiz that's hadurok
Jessica said what you couldn't possibly
know he said you won't believe it until
you see it and he thought I'm a seed he
suddenly saw how fertile was the ground
into which he had fallen and with this
realization the terrible purpose filled
him creeping through the empty space
within threatening to choke him with
grief he had seen two main branchings
along the way ahead in one he confronted
an old evil baron and send hello
grandfather
the thought of that path and what lay
along it sickened him
the other path held long patches of gray
obscurity except for peaks of violence
he had seen a warrior religion there a
fire spreading across the universe with
the Atreides green and black banner
waving at the head of fanatic legions
drunk on spiced liqueur gurney Halleck
and a few other of his father's min a
pitiful few were among them all marked
by the hawk symbol from the shrine of
his father's skull I can't go that way
he muttered that's what the old witches
of your school really want I don't
understand you Paul his mother said he
remained silent thinking like the seed
he was thinking with the race
consciousness he had first experienced
as terrible purpose he found that he no
longer could hate the Bene Jesuit or the
Emperor or even the harkonnens
they were all caught up in the need of
their race to renew its scattered
inheritance to cross and mingle and
infuse their bloodlines in a great new
pooling of gene
and the race knew only one sure way for
this the ancient way the tried and
certain way that rolled over everything
in its path jihad surely I cannot choose
that way he thought but he saw again in
his mind's eye the shrine of his
father's skull and the violence with the
green and black banner waving in its
midst
Jessica cleared her throat worried by
his silence then the Fremen will give us
sanctuary he looked up staring across
the green lighted tent at the inbred
patrician in lines of her face yes he
said that's one of the ways he nodded
yes they'll call me Maddy the one who
points the way
yes that's what they'll call me and he
closed his eyes thinking now my father I
can mourn you and he felt the tears
coursing down his cheeks book one of the
first novel ends here with the
revelations that the Baron Harkonnen is
actually the maternal grandfather of
paul the lady Jessica's own father
though this information is not known to
her or the Baron and also that they will
find sanctuary amongst the desert people
the Fremen Paul also senses a terrible
purpose a great jihad of violence that
will spread a religious war in his name
after managing to survive in the desert
for a while on their own Paul and
Jessica eventually do encounter the
Fremen the naive of this tribe still GAR
after viewing the fighting prowess of
Jessica her weirding way the special
martial arts of the many Jesuit he
agrees to allow Jessica and Paul to
enter the tribe on the neck addition
that they will teach them the weirding
way Jessica must play a very delicate
game using her knowledge of the
Sisterhood's mission ara protect Eva she
will manipulate the Freeman people in
order to preserve House Atreides the
superstitions maintained by the Freeman
detailed the coming of a prescient son
of AB in each s rate who would leave
them to freedom
this figure is referred to as the least
son alga even Freeman myth and this is
the son that will become the Mahdi the
Arabic word meaning the guided one of
the Freeman and lead them to freedom
long have the Freeman people been spat
upon and oppressed by the Imperium and a
myth such as this was highly appealing
to them thus from the moment Paul and
Jessica arrived on Arrakis the freeman
had believed that their prophecies were
being fulfilled the fact that the Mahdi
legend specifically had been planted on
doom indicates to Jessica that
conditions on doom are truly horrible
the MIDI legend she knew was reserved
for only the harshest environments where
a mini Jesuit would need the maximum
advantage over surrounding influences
over the course of the next two years
Paul would amass more and more power
respect and influence amongst the
Freeman people
he has established himself as a prophet
a powerful religious leader to the
Fremen
his skills in combat are now legendary
amongst the Freeman for he has trained a
squad of death commandos called the
fader King the most loyal and deadly
soldiers on all of Arrakis at this point
the Emperor Shaddam along with the Baron
are Conan and the rest of the Imperium
assumed that Paul and Jessica are dead
during this time Paul has taken the
Freeman woman Shawnee daughter of late
kinds as concubine they have a son
together named Leto for Paul's father
Jessica has become saya Deena of the
Fremen a rogue Reverend Mother
due to the misión era protect Eva many
French cultures such as the Freeman have
produced so-called wild Reverend mothers
who possess many of the skills of the
many Jesuit Reverend mothers but without
official training Jessica encounters one
of them during the spiced agony she
absorbs the dying Reverend mother's
consciousness and unblocks her own
genetic memory by converting the deadly
truths they're drugged the water of life
but the cost was greater than she
understood Jessica since before the
Harkonnen attack had been carrying the
daughter of Duke Leto Atreides
and when Jessica underwent the spice
agony unblocking her genetic memory
aleeah's genetic memory is unlocked as
well and in that instant she becomes a
reverend mother to alia is her mother
and her grandmother and her grandfather
the full maternal genetic bloodline in
one mind the many Jesuit consider a
child such as this to be abomination you
should have told us you were pregnant
Jessica found the voice that talked with
in the mutual awareness why this changes
both of you only mother what have we
done
Jessica sensed a force to shift in the
mutual awareness saw another mote
presence within the inward eye the other
mote darted wildly here they're circling
it radiated pure terror you'll have to
be strong the old Reverend mother's
image prescient said be thankful it is a
daughter you carry this would have
killed a male fetus alia you see was pre
born the shock and trauma that this
brought unto the unborn child was
catastrophic what happens when a person
does not have the time to establish
their own personality the weight of the
egos stretching back through the genetic
history becomes unbearable eventually
the ego memories of the person's
ancestors could assert themselves and
eventually govern the person's behavior
possession
alyas strangeness is frightening to the
Fremen
she is a child but not a child they do
not understand her there is yet
misunderstanding because of Aaliyah's
strangeness the women are fearful
because a child little more than an
infant talks of things that only adults
should know they do not understand the
change in the womb that made aliyah
different paul's concerned that he will
be the instigator of a jihad or holy war
led by the Fremen under his banner is
perhaps one of the most important motifs
in dune he worries that the religious
war will spread across the galaxy as
House Atreides and the Fremen
kill everyone in their path Paul thinks
that the reason for this religious war
is that it will invigorate the human
gene pool which has been stagnant during
the last ten thousand years into the but
Larian jihad Paul deeply desires to free
himself from these possible futures he
spends the rest of the book considering
his options in every situation
attempting to predict each outcome and
trying to take the course that will
prevent such bloody violence the jihad
is the embodiment of Paul's sense of
terrible purpose a cursed fate that he
feels he must resist during the time
with the Freeman Paul encounters the now
dead Lee at Khan's Imperial Planet
ologists who was an all but name one of
the Fremen Paul learns of the Fremen
plans to terraform the planet doom into
an Eden full of life guided by kinds
after kinds is murdered by the
harkonnens
it is Paul who begins to replace him as
the spiritual and military leader of the
Fremen the final test in Paul becoming a
freeman is for him to mount a sand worm
the worm riding ritual is a
coming-of-age ritual among the Fremen
people
and in that moment his vision is blocked
he has not seen this moment in his
prescience and therefore he does not
know the outcome it came from the
southeast a distant hissing ass and
whisper presently he saw the faraway
outline of the creatures track against
the dawn light and realized he had never
before seen a maker this large never
heard of one this size it appeared to be
more than half a league long and the
rise of the sand wave at its cresting
head was like the approach of a mountain
this is nothing I have seen my vision or
in life Paul cautioned himself he
hurried across the path of the thing to
take his stand caught up entirely by the
rushing needs of the moment Paul of
course survives this test and mounts his
first worm but the young men of the
tribe are not contended they clearly see
Paul as the strongest member of the
tribe and wonder why he has not called
out still GAR yet who has grown close to
both the idea of replacement or
recycling is important to the Fremen
water is scarce on Arrakis
so the Fremen used the water from the
dead corpses to replenish their wells
even in light of this Paul has no wish
to kill still Garn later the Fremen
discover a spice smuggling operation
taking place in their territory
Paul realizes that the operation is
being led by none other than gurney
Halleck former master of arms two House
Atreides he survived the Harkonnen raid
Paul reveals himself to gurney who
confirms to Paul that he is still his
Duke and he remains loyal to him
after leading gurney and his smuggler
men into a Freeman cavern several of the
so-called smugglers reveal themselves to
be sardick our soldiers in disguise they
attack but the Fremen kill all but a few
of them aw allow a few to escape so that
they can report back to house Harkonnen
of the fighting power of the freeman the
Baron Harkonnen in the time since the
raid on House Atreides has regained the
fiefdom of Arrakis he has manipulated
aging mint at the fair Howard into
serving him the Baron who resides on GD
Prime has placed his cruel nephew the
Beast Rabanne in charge of the people on
the planet dune fade ratha who the baron
intends to precede him has grown
impatient and wants the Baron dead in
one instance while raping a slave boy
the Baron is almost killed by a poison
needle that was implanted into the boy's
thigh the Baron knows that fade is to
blame he quickly realizes who fades
spies are within his guard he orders
them to be killed immediately the Baron
confronts fade ratha and chastises him
for the attempt on his life he tells the
teenager that one day not too far in the
future he will step down and allow a
drought that to succeed him the Baron
also assigns through fear to watch over
fame from this point on
for now fay decides not to make another
attempt on the Barons life eventually
the freeman attempt to force paul to
call out still gar but he refuses
instead all accepts his role as mu Adeeb
the prophetic leader he uses this road
to differentiate himself from still gars
more secular position the freeman accept
this and also accept paul's other role
as duke of Arrakis paul has also learned
that the Baron Harkonnen has cut off
robin in supplies and reinforcements it
will then be easy
for the Fremen people to take control of
Arrakis from the harkonnens
and they are ready to fight they are
willing to die for their liberation
gurney Halleck upon seeing the lady
jessica quickly attacks her still under
the belief that she was the traitor to
house a tradies he threatens to kill her
while he holds a knife to her throat
Paul however convinces gurney that
Jessica was not the traitor but that it
was instead the dr. Yui who betrayed
House Atreides gurney becomes
overwhelmed with shame and asked to be
killed but Paul refuses in Earth's
history messianic figures are typically
passive Jesus for example though much
violence has occurred in his name since
his death what works of sci-fi and
fantasy are different in them the Savior
or the one will often lead his people to
triumph by violent means
Aragorn daenerys targaryen Paul is
destined to fill the most common role in
fantasy and science fiction the Savior
who will lead his adopted people to
victory over their enemies by using
violence and Paul remains aware of the
significance of his power and the jihad
that may be a consequence of that power
what Paul was not the quiz ATS had iraq
yet he had realized something during
Gurney's attempt on his mother's life he
had not foreseen it in any vision his
body had slowly acquired a certain spice
tolerance that made prescient visions
fewer and fewer dimmer and dimmer the
solution of erred obvious to him I will
drown the maker
we will see now whether I am the quiz
ATS had a rap who can survive the test
that the Reverend mother's have survived
Paul decides to take the deadly water of
life the truth seer drug which no male
has ever survived and it came to pass in
the third year of the desert war that
Paul Muad'Dib lay alone in the cave of
burns beneath the key SWA hangings of an
inner cell and he lay as one dead caught
up in the revelation of the water of
life his being translated beyond the
boundaries of time by the poison that
gives life thus was the prophecy made
that the Leeson alga [ __ ] might be both
dead and alive after three weeks in a
coma
Paul emerges as the quiz asshat Iraq he
looks into space and sees that the
Emperor and the harkonnens have amassed
a huge are ma de to invade the planet to
regain the control that Rabanne has lost
some time later the CH were alia and
late till the second reside is attacked
and the sardick our soldiers kill lake
tow and take alia prisoner alia is then
brought to the capital city of Arrakis
Arrakeen by the Emperor Shaddam himself
it is here that the story comes to its
climax my dear baron the emperor said
become acquainted with the sister of MU
Adeeb the system the Baron shifted his
attention to the Emperor I do not
understand I too sometimes err on the
side of caution the Emperor said it has
been reported to me that you're unhappy
today poll or regions exhibit evidence
of human activity but that's impossible
the Baron protested the worms
there's San clear to the these people
seem to be able to avoid the worms the
Emperor send the child sat down on the
dais beside that the
mangled her feet over the edge kicking
them there was such an air of sureness
in the way she appraised her
surroundings the baron stared at the
kicking feet the way they moved the
black road the wing of sandals beneath
the fabric unfortunately the emperor
said i only sit in five troop carriers
with a light attack force to pick up
prisoners for questioning we barely got
away with three prisoners and one
carrier mind you baron mice our dakar
were almost overwhelmed by a force
composed mostly of women children and
old men this child here was in command
of one of the attacking groups you see
your majesty the Baron said you see how
they are I allowed myself to be captured
the child said I did not want to face my
brother and have to tell him that his
son had been killed only a handful of
our men got away the Emperor said got
away you hear that we'd had them - the
child said except for the flames my
Sardar car used the attitudinal jets on
their carriers as flame throwers the
Emperor said a move of desperation and
the only thing that got them away with
their three prisoners mark that my dear
baron sardick are forced to retreat in
confusion from women and children and
old men we must attack them in force the
baron rasp
we must destroy every last vestige of
silence the emperor roared he pushed
himself forward on his throne do not
abuse my intelligence any longer you
stand there in your foolish innocence
and majesty the truth Sayre said he
waved her to silence you say you don't
know about the activity we found nor the
fighting qualities of these superb
people the Emperor lifted himself half
off his throne what do you take me for
the Baron took two backward steps
thinking it was Rabanne he has done this
to me
Rabanne has and this fake dispute with
do Plato the Emperor purred sinking back
into his throne how beautifully you
maneuvered it Majesty the Baron pleaded
what are you
silence the old Binni Jesuit put a hand
on the Emperor's shoulder leaned close
to whisper in his ear the child seated
on the Dia's stopped kicking her feet
and said make him afraid some more
Shaddam I shouldn't enjoy this but I
find the pleasure impossible to suppress
quiet child the Emperor said a lean
forward put a hand on her head stared at
the Baron is it possible Baron could you
be as simple-minded as my truth Sayer
suggests do you not recognise this child
daughter of your ally Duke Leto my
father was never his ally the child said
my father is dead and this old Harkonnen
beast has never seen me before the Baron
was reduced to stupefied glaring when he
found his voice it was only to rasp
Who I am alia daughter of the Duke Leto
and the lady Jessica sister of Duke Paul
Muad'Dib the child said she pushed
herself off the Dia's dropped to the
floor of the onion chamber my brother
has promised to have your head atop this
battle standard and I think he shall be
hush child and the Emperor said and he
sank back into his throne hand to chin
studying the Baron I do not take the
Emperor's orders alia said she turned
looked up at the old Reverend mother
she knows the Emperor glanced up at his
truth Sayer
what does she mean this child is an
abomination you babble old woman Illya
said you don't know how it was yet you
rattle on like a purr blind fool Illya
closed her eyes took a deep breath and
held it the old Reverend Mother groaned
and staggered alia opened her eyes that
is how it was she said a cosmic accident
and you played your part in it the
Reverend mother held out both hands
palms pushed the air toward alia what is
happening here
the Emperor demanded child can you truly
project your thoughts into the mind of
another that is not how it is at all
alia said unless I am born as you I
cannot think as you kill her the old
woman muttered and clutched the back of
the throne for support kill her the
sunken old eyes glared at alia silence
the Emperor said and he studied oddly a
child can you communicate with your
brother my brother knows I'm here alia
sending can you tell him to surrender as
the price of your life alia smiled up at
him with clear innocence I shall not do
that she said the Baron stumbled forward
to stand beside alia Majesty he pleaded
I knew nothing of interrupt me once more
baron the emperor said and you will lose
the powers of interruption forever he
kept his attention focused on alia
studying her through slitted lids you
will not a
can you read my mind what I'll do if you
disobey me I've already said I cannot
read minds she said but one does not
need to let the thief to read your
intentions the emperor scowled child
your cause is hopeless
I have but to rally my forces and reduce
this planet too it is not that simple
Alya sin she looked at the two guilds
Minh asked them it's not wise to go
against my desires the Emperor said you
should not deny me the least thing my
brother comes now a listen even an
emperor may tremble before mu a deed for
he has the strength of a righteousness
and heaven smiles upon him the Emperor
surged to his feet this play has gone
far enough
I will take your brother and this planet
and grind into the moon crumbled and
shook around them there came a sudden
cascade of sand behind the throne where
the hutment was coupled to the Emperor's
ship the abrupt flickering tightening of
skin pressure told of a wide-area shield
being activated I told you Ilia said my
brother comes it is at this moment under
cover of a giant sandstorm Paul and his
army of Freeman warriors attacked the
capital city riding on the backs of
dozens of giants and worms they destroy
the shield wall in the chaos alia kills
the Baron Harkonnen and escapes the
Emperor
I'm sorry grandfather alia said you've
met the Atreides gum Jabbar she got to
her feet
dropped a dark needle from her hand
unlike Duke Leto Atreides the Baron
Harkonnen never saw the potential of the
Freeman he viewed them as savages and
that was the death of him alia then goes
to seek out and slit the throats of any
wound in Harkonnen and sardick our
soldiers as freeman tradition dictates
upon witnessing the calming onslaught
the Emperor Shaddam and the Reverend
mother Gaius
realize that they have but one weapon
left to them treachery the Fremen
quickly defeat the Emperor sardick are
and Paul takes his place at the Arrakeen
governor's mansion which was the home of
House Atreides when they first arrived
on the planet doom Paul has one of the
captives sardick our soldiers relay a
message to shadow
Paul wishes to discuss the Emperor
surrender at this point however Paul can
still see the jihad which worries him
the Emperor and his entourage arrived at
the mansion the emperor has instructed
to fear to kill Paul using a poison
needle but do fear refuses he dies in
Paul's arms due to a poison that the
Baron had administered to him in secret
the Emperor then threatens to order the
ships of the Lance Iraq who hovered
above the planet to attack the Fremen
but Paul orders the spacing yield to
force the Lance Arad ships to leave the
guild obeys he who controls the spice
and that was now Pohl Atreides the
Emperor was powerless Paul sees the
Reverend Mother as well
Reverend Mother Gaius Helen Mohan Paul
said it has been a long time since
Caledon hasn't it she looked past him at
his mother said well Jessica I see that
your son is indeed the one for that you
can be forgiven even the abomination of
your daughter
all stilled a cold and piercing Engler
and said you have never had the right or
cause to forgive my mother anything the
old woman locked eyes with him try your
tricks on me old witch Paul said where
is your gum Jabar try looking into that
place where you dare not look you'll
find me there staring out at you
the old woman dropped her gaze have you
nothing to say
Paul demanded I welcome you to the ranks
of humans
she muttered don't besmirch that poll
raised his voice observe her comrades
this a mini Jesuit Reverend Mother
patient in a patient cause she could
wait with her sisters nineteen
generations for the proper combination
of genes and environment to produce the
one person their schemes required
observe her she knows that the nineteen
generations have produced that person
here I stand but I will never do her
bidding
Jessica the old woman screamed silence
him silence him yourself
Jessica said Paul glared at the old
woman for your part in this
I could gladly have you strangled he
said you couldn't prevent it he snapped
as she stiffened in rage but I think it
better punishment that you live out your
years never able to touch me or bend me
to a single thing your scheming desires
Jessica what have you done the old woman
demanded I'll give you only one thing
Paul said you saw part of what the race
means but how poorly you saw it you
think to control breeding and intermix a
select few according to your master plan
how little you understand of what you
mustn't speak of these things
the old woman hissed silence Paul roared
the word seemed to take substance as it
twisted through the air between them
under Paul's control the old woman
reeled back into the arms of those
behind her face blank with shock at the
power with which he had seized her
psyche Jessica she whispered Jessica I
remember your gum Jabar all said you
remember mine I can kill you with a word
the freeman around the ball glanced
knowingly at each
did the legend not say and his word
shall carry death eternal to those who
stand against righteousness it is here
that fade ratha har conan comes forth it
all had been born a girl as the
sisterhood intended he would have likely
married fade Ralpha but instead they
cannot coexist fade challenges called to
a duel fade cheats but still Falls to
Paul Muad'Dib nonetheless the emperor's
last hope is that Fidan ring also a
product of the Bene jesuit breeding plan
who was almost a quiz etcetera himself
would slay Paul but Finn ring refuses
feeling a special connection with Paul
the emperor is out of options
Paul ascends the throne and is allowed
to marry the Emperor's daughter the
princess Irulan he ensures taani that
the marriage is strictly political and
that he will remain loyal to her book 1
in the doom saga ends here with Paul's
ascension to emperor of the Imperium as
Paul does not know how he intends to
avert the religious jihad we also do not
know how he plans to bring peace the
novel presents only one allusion to
Paul's future plans they sense that I
must take the throne but they cannot
know I do it to prevent the jihad as
emperor of the Imperium all would be the
most powerful person in the universe
Paul hopes to use this power to prevent
the deaths of millions of
each chapter header in doom includes a
quote by the princess Irulan many about
Paul by the end we do not know whether
these quotations are in praise of a
great religious leader who brought a
time of peace or in praise of a person
who brought a deadly war we still do not
know whether the Fremen will become
soldiers of war or guardians of peace
the ending is left ambiguous the action
in doom reaches its peak toward the
final pages and the novel ends suddenly
and anticlimactically many avenues
remain unexplored Paul rising to ruler
of the Imperium and the Freeman
regaining control of Arrakis is a
complete reversal of the status from the
novel's opening at the beginning of dune
shadow and the barren dominated the
Atreides and the Freeman the power
structure of Arrakis has changed since
Paul was on Caledon Paul is not only now
Duke of Arrakis but he is also the new
emperor of the universe the Freeman will
soon turn their planet into the garden
paradise that kind spoke of and they
have long desired once this change
occurs however we wonder how the
Freeman's culture will change because of
it doom is possibly the most influential
sci-fi novel of all time it combines
sci-fi and fantasy with the
multi-layered interactions of important
social issues concerning human social
interaction religion and genetic
development dune is widely considered to
be far ahead of its time
in pointing out the importance of
preserving the ecology of a planet the
conservation of resources and by
addressing the complexities of religion
doom explored a topic that surprisingly
was rarely addressed in science fiction
prior dooms portrayal of the downfall of
the Galactic Empire has been compared to
Edward Gibbons decline and fall of the
Roman Empire
Lorenzo de Tomaso outlined similarities
between the two works highlighting the
excesses of Emperor Shaddam and the
Baron Harkonnen the Emperor loses his
effectiveness as a ruler from excess of
ceremony and pompous de Tomaso
points out that the Baron is similarly
materially indulgent corrupt and
sexually decadent Gibbons decline and
fall blames the fall of Rome on the rise
of Christianity complacency weakened the
soldiers of Rome and left it open to
attack
similarly the Emperor's sardick our
fighters are no match for the Fremen of
Arrakis because of their own
overconfidence and the Freeman's
capacity for self-sacrifice the Freeman
put the community before themselves in
every instance while the world outside
wallows in luxury at the expense of
others Doom has before been criticized
for presenting a sexist portrayal of
women this couldn't be further from the
truth
Paul's approach to power required his
upbringing under the female-oriented
many Jesuit without his mother's
training he would have never become the
quizzes hadurok though the sisterhood
claims that they only exist to serve
they secretly operate as a long
dominating shadow government behind all
of the Great Houses and their marriages
or divisions the doom universe only
appear
to be patriarch who at first glitz
throughout the novel as Paul becomes
more and more powerful more alien to the
reader
Jessica remains human mentoring Paul at
crucial moments Frank Herbert did six
years of research before he began
writing dune he spent a year and a half
writing the first novel he conceived of
a long novel what became a trilogy was
initially one book about the messianic
convulsions and periodically overtake
mankind demagogues fanatics con game
artists the innocent and the not so
innocent bystanders all were to have a
part in this drummer this grows from my
theory that superheroes are disastrous
for humankind even if we find a real
hero whatever or whoever that may be
eventually fallible mortals take over
the power structure that always comes
into being around such a leader Frank
Herbert doom Genesis Frank Herbert
understood that during difficult times
people become perfectly willing to give
over their agency all decision-making
capacity to any leader who can quote
wrap himself in the myth fabric of
society
Hitler Churchill Franklin Roosevelt and
Stalin are among the examples Frank
Herbert names Frank Herbert points out
that although these figures often have
larger-than-life appearances each
possesses human faults this is a major
theme of the doom saga never give your
critical faculties away to people in
power regardless of how admirable these
people may seem to be
the novel dune understands that power
attracts the corruptible people who want
power for the sake of it
frank herbert's suggests that a certain
proportion of such people are imbalanced
or perhaps even insane Frank Herbert
believed that humanity must continue to
evolve or it would die I now believe
that evolution or D evolution never in
short of death that no society has ever
achieved an absolute pinnacle that all
humans are not created equal in fact I
believe attempts to create some abstract
equalization create amorous of injustice
'as that rebound on the equalizers equal
justice and equal opportunity our ideals
we should seek but we should recognize
that humans administer the ideals and
that humans do not have equal ability
this quote may be off-putting to some
but all it is saying is that yes some
humans are smarter than others some have
greater physical prowess regardless of
this we should embrace these differences
while still providing equal justice and
protection under the law and not pretend
that all humans are the same in the next
part of this series we will explore the
second novel in Frank Herbert's original
doom series doom Messiah which details
the consequences of Paul's ascension to
ruler of the universe or more doom check
out the videos in the doom playlist on
my channel
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]